Hey, this is Presh Talwalkar
A party has 100 people who are either liars or truth tellers
Liars always lie
And truth tellers always speak the truth
After the party is over
You ask each person
"How many truth tellers did you shake hands with?"
Each person gave a different answer
Ranging from the numbers 0 to 99
The answers were the whole numbers from 0 to 99
How many liars were at the party?
Give this problem a try and when you're ready, keep watching the video for the solution
This logic problem seems impossible
Because you do not know
Which people shook hands with each other
However
We can deduce from their answers
How many people at the party were truth tellers
And how many people are liars
We'll start by labeling each person
We'll say person 99 is the one who replied
To have shaken hands with 99 truth tellers
Similarly, person 98
said to have shaken hands with 98 truth tellers
We'll continue this labeling all the way down to person 0
Who shook hands with 0 truth tellers
Let's consider first person 99
Imagine person 99 was a truth teller
What could we deduce from that?
If person 99 is a truth teller
That would mean person 99 must have shaken hands
With everyone else
All other 99 people at the party
And
Because that person said they shook hands with 99 truth tellers
That means everyone else at the party
Must also be a truth teller
But person 99 would have then also have shook hands with person 0
Who is said to have shaken hands with 0 truth tellers
How can person 0 have shaken hands with 0 truth tellers?
and be a truth teller?
One possibility is that 99 and 0 did not shake hands
This would mean person 99 is a liar
Or
Person 0 shook hands only with liars
Which would also mean person 99 is a liar
It's not logically possible for person 99 to be a truth teller
Therefore, person 99 must be a liar
We will identify person 99 accordingly
Now that we know person 99 is a liar
What else can we figure out?
Let's look at person 98
If person 98 is a truth teller
That would mean person 98 shook hands with persons 0 to 97
And all of those people must be truth tellers
We can make this deduction because we know 99 is a liar
If you exclude person 99
We're left with person 0 to 97
Which are only 98 people
So the only way person 98 could be a truth teller
And shake hands with 98 people
Is that person 98 would have shaken hands with person 0 to 97
who must all be truth tellers
But this would mean person 98 also shook hands with person 0
Who is said to have shaken hands with 0 truth tellers
Once again this is possible only if 98 and 0 did not shake hands
Which would make person 98 a liar
Or
Person 0 shook hands only with liars
Which would once again mean that person 98 is a liar
In either possibility
We can conclude person 98 is not a truth teller
And therefore, person 98 must be a liar
We will label person 98 accordingly
Now we can continue this process
We can then inductively prove persons 97, 96, and so on, all the way down to person 1
must all be liars
We'll label each person accordingly
What about person 0?
We've already figured out that persons 1 to person 99 is a liar
Everyone else at the party is a liar
Therefore, person 0 necessarily shake hands with only liars
There are 0 truth tellers that person 0 can shake hands with
This means person 0 is telling the truth
and is therefore a truth teller
So the answer to this problem
Is that there are 99 liars
Persons 1 to 99
And exactly 1 truth teller
Which is person 0
Did you figure out this problem?
Thanks for watching this video
Please subscribe to my channel
I make videos on math and game theory
You can catch me on my blog, MindYourDecisions
Which you can follow on Facebook, Google+, and Patreon
You can catch me at social media @preshtalwalkar
And if you liked this video, please check out my books
There are links in the video description